foreign
and
want to welcome everyone to our
lesson today
this is why you need AI for decision
making for business strategies and
applications
uh we're here with Professor Don huesman
of Wharton
School of Business School of Management
I should say and
he directs the Wharton online program
although he'll be handing over to a
you leaders soon
just want to say welcome Don thanks for
being here
um here's the agenda we'll be talking
about today and
We'll be asking a couple of questions
about you along the way so keep an eye
out for those polls
we'll discuss Ai and business and Don
will discuss why it's important what
role it can play in your organization
and then what this program offers to you
um
we'll also talk about how this program
gets you ready
face the future and prepare your
organization
computer challenges
I'll go over the enrollment steps and
we'll take your questions My Name by the
way is Stuart Creek I'm with simplylearn
who is partner
with Wharton for delivering this online
program and your guide today is Dr
Houston
don't let Don you can come in and
tell the audience about yourself
I am not hearing you Don
you're speaking
Connor you're on uh on the on the
foreign
okay Don are you on the webinar
I'm going to check I think uh Professor
Guzman needs to reconnect him a little
difficulty with the WebEx
interface he'll be back in just a second
um I will say that he is the managing
director of Wharton online
a lecturer Wharton Executive Education
and the founding director of the Wharton
Innovation group
as soon as he's back with us
we'll get into the webinar
hold on for just a second let me see
foreign
foreign hi
I lost you there for a moment we were we
were just talking before the start of
the webinar about some of the
difficulties with the WebEx platform and
I want to let the audience know that
we'll be moving to zoom as an
organization but
this is exactly the kind of thing that I
mentioned
so welcome back and I'll
back to this
so we I just introduced you as the
managing director of Wharton online and
um you might want to
tell folks a little bit more about your
role and your background and how that's
changing
sure thanks Stuart um I have been a
Wharton for a very long time actually in
multiple roles
most recently I've been the managing
director for our online learning
initiatives they started uh well this
particular initiative started around
2011 when the moocs were new and
exciting and the the dean and the
Provost to the University of
Pennsylvania asked Wharton to get
involved and the project was handed to
Mead so we have been experimenting with
the various forms of online education
since then have uh still have a variety
of moocs that are done through sort of
self-study and then we've found a lot of
luck working with the organizations like
simply learn to bring a more facilitated
experience to the world around current
topics that are being researched by War
certain faculty
so we have employed about a half of the
Wharton standing faculty in various
programs of study and this one in
particular brings together
I can't remember if it's six or seven of
our research faculty associated with
exploring Ai and machine learning
so what we're going to talk about today
is really about a business look at at
the field of artificial intelligence and
machine learning not so much in
engineering look but rather how to make
sense of AI as both a resource to manage
as a general manager in a business but
also as a an opportunity for bringing
your organization up the learning curve
into what is emerging as a new set of
Technologies for
augmenting our decision-making processes
so that's a brief overview of how I got
to the table today uh Stuart I'll turn
it back over to you thank you
and uh as John mentioned he's going to
speak about the evolving role of AI in
business as a tool to add to the toolkit
of organizational managers
um
so
just as a preamble data drives the
economy as we we all know in the
transformation of business to the
digital domain
uh it's only gotten
far faster during the pandemic where we
all instantly had to move to work from
home I remember an executive early in
the pandemic who said if they had told
us we needed all to work remotely we
would have told management it would take
six months and 10 million dollars to do
that and when it happened it took three
days with no budget so we've all had to
adapt to a new data-driven world
that it was creeping up on us over the
last decade or two but now
kind of the environment we all live in
so John how does uh how does an
organization deal with that
metamorphosis
so what we've been suggesting is that AI
is such a fast-moving field that it's
important to take kind of a portfolio
approach for a larger organization to
to begin to build capacity inside the
organization both to use data in its in
its structured forms but to use Ai and
experiment with AI to explore the vast
amount of data that is actually
unstructured so the amount of data that
has been
growing in our organizations in our data
warehouses is probably 80 percent now
unstructured and the intelligence in
that data is the gold we're looking at
the end of the rainbow in terms of
trying to use these new technologies to
to both test the hypotheses that form
the basis of our own thinking about our
businesses but also to manage uncertain
environments such as the kinds of
circumstances we find ourselves in today
as some of us emerge from covid
others are slow to emerge from covid
with War and the possibility of
recession looming next year that
uncertainty makes our usual
decision-making processes more
complicated and whatever we can do to
bring data to help us better test our
hypothy season explore our decision
options is is worth the investment of
time for sure and of money with that let
me ask you Stuart for the next slide
so this slide is from
um a a report originally put together by
Mackenzie there's a seminal report that
TCS in India is also
developed looking at
the critical role for
someone who stands between
an understanding of the business case of
the c-suite issues of the business
models that have been created and
launched in our organizations and the
data scientists so as I mentioned this
course that we've put together around AI
for decision making is not an
engineering course not intended to be
it's really uh intended to provide a
general manager what we're referring to
is that Central column your role as
someone who knows enough about the the
tools that are available and the the
nature of exploring structured
unstructured data that you can in fact
translate
the information that is coming out of
your data stores and data collection
processes into a forecast model or a
decision-making model that will help
hone decisions that are made
at various levels of management inside
your organizations so the idea is to
at the end of this course to have you in
a position to understand enough about
the AI Technologies and machine learning
technologies that are taking shape on
the horizon to be able to help c-suite
Executives and Senior Management at your
organization form questions that those
data can in fact help inform so it's
that middle role that we're after and
trying to explore by looking at cases of
companies who are at the Leading Edge of
working with new models to extract
real information out of the loose data
particularly that that's found in vast
new stores of unstructured data
um in that regard I might mention that
in the nature of unstructured data we
have a large collection of data that
comes to us through our email stores and
voicemail stores uh our uh video stores
our audio stores
the large quantities of data that are
generated by analytical processes that
run on our websites and that fill out a
profile of what customers are doing as
they move from exploration to purchase
all of these stores of data are
different than what we faced
some 20 years ago when we had relational
databases and spreadsheets and
tabular data that could be organized by
rows and columns and that could be used
in a more direct way to predict and to
drive spreadsheet forecasting models
either those that are based in Worlds of
uncertainty where we would rely more on
scenario planning and sensitivity
analysis
versus the optimization models that we
would turn to should there be a clear
set of of choices and expected forecasts
so all of that relied in years past on
the existence of relational database
Management systems and other forms of
structured data the new tools that are
emerging are intended to provide us a
way of mining the data that comes to us
in largely unstructured forms and that's
the point of this course without the
amount of storage for the next slide
so we're going to show you a variety of
examples that come from
organizations that have successfully
used Ai and machine learning to develop
new sales and marketing strategies so
we'll be looking at the work that has
been done by modern marketing
organizations to develop a personalized
recommendation engines and to explore
other marketing strategies that are
informed by large transactional
databases and by large analytical
databases of of customer behavior that
augments our transactional data stores
we'll be looking at Finance applications
such as the ability in Midstream for an
organization that provides
e-commerce transactions for example
an identification of a pattern of
behavior by customer that might suggest
that there's fraud at work and to
intervene in the transaction to take
further steps to assure the security of
a transaction
that might look initially suspicious and
we'll look at a third dimension calling
on faculty who are associated with our
people analytics initiative to examine
how in fact
Ai and machine learning can associate
can can be used to help us with that
most critical Resource Management task
we all face which is dealing with your
decisions around hiring around promotion
and around
managing performance so AI has a strong
role to play in that Dimension as well
but of course it is uh also important to
recognize the ethical and security
issues that arise whenever we're using
technology in the management of people
which is as critical uh if not more so
than in the management of our
organizations through new sales and
marketing and financial processes
I was going to make a quick mention of
a
webinar that we did with the
founder of zest money is a fintech firm
um
in India and
the reason I bring it up is that that
type of fintech firm which offers micro
credit or instant credit uh to Consumers
can only exist because of AI as you
talked about finance and fraud detection
and that type of thing
um
it turns out that the flip side of that
is to determine who's a good credit risk
from all of that as you said
unstructured data about a consumer's
spending habit and
other history and when a consumer gives
permission to zest money
to mine into that it can come back and
say
you know these are the types of levels
of transactions that we think this
person is
capable of handling and repaying and
it's
it's an amazing type of environment so
that's another example of how AI in one
of these domains
has opened up new opportunities for
businesses
I just wanted to mention that one
and um
just to build on that story the uh
one of the realities in in even the G20
countries is the uh is the problem we
Face let's say in the United States for
example
of people who lack FICO credit scores
and therefore can cannot qualify for a
uh for a prime rate based loan and this
has uh the deleterious effect of the of
the making worse The Divide between the
Haves and the have-nots because
individuals who might otherwise be
entirely credit worthy don't have the
FICO score to get that truck or to buy a
a house or to build the kind of wealth
that translates from one generation into
the next
and yet even though in the United States
at least 40 percent of households lack
FICO scores that would allow for or a
prime rate based loan the terms of the
matter is the vast majority of those
individuals are in fact better worthy
and it is as a result of the application
of AI and machine learning and other
fintech tools that companies have been
in a position to underwrite the credit
worthiness of an individual
facing more traditional financial
institutions this is particularly
relevant of course even more so in parts
of the world where retail banking
doesn't have a strong route where the
you know the individuals don't have the
common practice of of connecting with a
local Banker at a local branch it's just
in some parts of the world that doesn't
happen whether you know there are vast
areas where retail banking isn't even
available and therefore the use of new
technology for transaction processing
and for manager Financial life becomes
more critical
and then
the example of building uh
credit worthiness for people who don't
have the traditional credit scores
um you know the effect of that for the
business is that they get a whole bunch
of new customers who expand their
revenue streams so it it works for
societal benefit individual consumer
benefit and business benefit all at once
so great
um so
in order to participate in this
revolution
people especially at the at the
managerial director level need to
really have an understanding of the
field and what it can do for them right
exactly and that that requires a certain
um technical exposure to the to the
terminology that the data scientists and
the I.T Engineers will be using uh in uh
building out and developing a portfolio
of AI or machine learning projects at
your company so we're hoping that this
course is a way for you to level set you
know with an understanding of of some
fundamental Technologies like what
constitutes Big Data what constitutes AI
how is machine learning uh conceived of
in contemporary projects both internal
to a larger company in your applications
Development Group but for smaller and
mid-sized companies what might be
available on the open market from
consultants and other supporting
organizations
we're hoping that you'll come out away
from this course some understanding the
difference between supervised and
unsupervised deep learning and the cases
in which both forms of deep learning
algorithmic based
information processing is put in play by
development organizations
there as I mentioned with regards to our
concerns regarding HR applications there
are many ethical
circumstances and corporate
organizational risks that can be
associated with AI algorithms can be as
biased as individuals in decisions
around hiring and promotion and
performance
assessment and looking to the ways in
which
AI applications can either introduce and
spread bias in an undetected way or can
be in some circumstances increasingly a
murky and Trend and not transparent
around the processes or the data points
that lead to a particular AI
recommendation so all of those are
critically important issues for General
management to take into consideration
and for those in the non-profit sector
or in the government sector there are
issues associated with governance
to sort of guides at guard rails for the
applications development that might be
happening in your organization
uh without let me ask Stuart for the
next slide
oh and I think this is your poll Stuart
I'll let you take it from here
um this is one of the polls I mentioned
and I want to open that up to the
audience
and this first poll is
um to ask why you have not yet
uh engaged in the program of this type
to help you gain that AI expertise
you're here today because you're
interested in adding that
capability set to your own personal
toolkit so
um is there a reason why you haven't
done that and you can give us one two
three or all four reasons
um
I'll leave this open for another 15
seconds or so
close it in about five seconds
and here is the poll result
and
about three-fifths of the audience say
that they don't feel like a program that
would give them practical exposure or
things that they can point to as
practical examples of what they've done
with the skill set
um to be able to go back to their
organization or even to a new
organization and say
this is how I have
applied
these Concepts
um
then about a quarter of the audience has
each of the other
three choices yeah
not finding a completely comprehensive
curriculum not being able to learn from
pre-recorded videos on your own or not
having enough time in your work schedule
so
I suspect that the reason why so many
people chose also this issue about
practical exposure has to do with the
nature of this topic one of the things
that is a bit different about Wharton
programming in the online uh efforts of
professional development is we tend to
to focus on issues that are not settled
science so basically the Wharton School
doesn't present oh here's a a series of
courses in learning how to program an R
to accomplish certain kinds of
activities you know that settled science
what we do is we draw on frankly the top
academic Minds in the world who are
involved with research around questions
that are open and they're unsettled and
what we try to do is set a table so that
on one side of the table we have the top
Minds from Academia and on the other
side of the table we're hoping to draw
the top Minds from business practice
that would be the people on this call
and where we have the opinion that it's
in the conversation between the two
sides of that table that new knowledge
emerges to help inform respond answers
to these unanswered questions that are
on the table regarding where is AI going
it's moving very fast
the
programs of study that we have been
involved with even last year is very
different from what we're facing this
year
a year or two ago the issue of machine
learning through structured application
of knowledge experts was wasn't at the
front burner in terms of of work being
done in this field today what's on the
front burner is actually
unstructured machine learning that is an
application of algorithms for improving
forecasting capability
at a scale and a speed of use of data
that that actually makes it difficult
for human beings to follow and those
issues now are a relevant in trying to
understand again some of those ethical
considerations that I pointed to earlier
so it's moving fast it's changing on a
regular basis this is what excites
people who are on the faculty at Wharton
and the opportunity to engage with
informed practitioners from around the
world such as we're hoping to convene in
this program is uh is is Hope is helpful
in terms of moving that research agenda
forward but also helpful in trying to
fill in the some detail around what's
really working in this space as we know
it today so the faculty can bring
research from the organizations they're
currently working with we're hoping you
bring context from your own firm your
own role your own
uh industry to
what we are suggesting might be possible
so in that regard we will have lots of
online discussions to supplement the
self-paced part of the of the curriculum
well we hope to have uh to expose you to
a variety of Industries in a variety of
examples of how these new technologies
are beginning to to uh prove their worth
we will have uh assignments and quizzes
around what we know now regarding the
state of the art in Ai and machine
learning but the intent here is to
provide busy professionals like
yourselves or people who might be
actively involved with raising a young
family a chance to fit a program of
study of this type into your busy
lifestyle so we're looking for oh three
to five hours a week over the course of
the next three months for you to explore
some pre-recorded material that'll set
age for interaction that happens in the
in the course in other modalities
I might ask you for the next slide
Stuart
yeah and
the culmination of that three-month
period is your the certificate you earn
from Wharton online
that certifies that you covered this
material that you've engaged in the
program actively and that you've
gained understanding of the concepts so
worked with those case studies and
you've also as Don said
brought your experience to the
discussion so that you can then take
away from it
um insights into how AI can be applied
in your own organization
the uh
online experience
um
are different from just self-paced
moocs or massively online open courses
that that Don referred to before so
um
it's a entirely different experience
right then
uh yes yeah and in fact the
um
[Music]
well we're hoping to do is to um
is to open the floor for considerations
and examples and questions and
applications that you all might have
been exposed to to complement the
Consulting engagements and uh projects
that were funded on campus that are
driving uh the work of our AI oriented
research centers I mentioned earlier we
have faculty from the people analytics
initiative who have joined this course
to look at the applications of AI to
decisions around
matters associated with the human
resource management we have also faculty
from our customer analytics initiative
we'll be looking at the new ways to the
companies are using unstructured data to
inform marketing related decisions and
as I mentioned earlier we have faculty
from our Stephen Center for innovation
in finance to talk to the issues
associated with new applications of of
AI machine learning for financial
services I might take a second to answer
Conrad's question here who posted in the
Q a uh the question if the class is
designed for management level then
there's no need to learn the details of
practical exposure but if the class is
designed for the working level then
hand-on practices are needed which one
is this so I will challenge your
assumption Conrad the I think the well
our experience of Wharton has been and
we've seen this backed up with research
done both at McKenzie and TCS is that
the reason most business analytics
projects fail and most of them fail in
terms of delivering value for the
investment is the lack of someone who
stands between the management level
and the Practical level of data
warehousing and application development
someone who acts as a translator between
the senior Executives or those who have
p l responsibility at your firm who have
in their minds working hypotheses a
theory of their firm of why in a mature
or competitive
Marketplace a customer would pick
services and products from our company
versus some of their competitors there's
a there's a theory a hypothesis around
that question that only someone who is
in a translator role can tease out by
informing a question shaping a question
so that data can actually be applied to
check that hypothesis and see if it's
actually true we've gone through
multiple
unprecedented changes in our management
of our firms and our economies over the
last three years first putting large
segments of our economy into a deep
freeze and now slowly defrosting
components of the economy in a world
that has learned a whole lot about
managing Supply chains about
communicating in manners that are not
face to face and in
addressing a Marketplace that is now
entirely
disrupted
in the space of retail sales in a way
that builds on disruptions that happen
before covet so in all of these
uncertain circumstances the the tried
and true knowledge that informs the boss
that informs senior people at your
organization Isn't So tried and true
anymore and requires exposure to what's
the data really saying something that
may have worked five years ago for
positioning your firm for success in a
crowded field may not be working today
and if I can just just use again one
example of that in the retail space
at least in North America we have seen
extraordinary disruption to
organizations who have large retail
Footprints in Suburban shopping malls
and in cities around the country who
have found themselves facing bankruptcy
names like Sears and Neiman Marcus and
many other big box stores are in trouble
and yet in the midst of all of this
chaos you see these extraordinary Rising
Stars like for example Lululemon on
Trader Joe's and
Sephora who are actually rapidly growing
in the same retail space that has seen
such Devastation
what is what we are seeing at Warden in
studying these successes our
organizations that have learned how to
apply data to inform and omnichannel
Retail strategy and that kind of work
can't be done by the wisened gray-haired
here I am I've got a lot of gray hair
myself why isn't old gray-haired
leadership of the organization Nora can
be handled by The Young Turks who are
fresh out of engineering school and
ready to crank up those Tableau systems
for creating beautiful data charts it
takes someone in the middle someone who
understands the value of Tableau and of
other ways to represent data and to
extract data and to gather data along
with someone who can talk to the c-suite
executives and and extract the
underlying assumptions behind the
decisions they make on a daily basis
that's what McKinsey identified as the
critical role in a successful business
analytics project and as I say TCS did
as well so that's what we're trying to
shape this course is for in between
those two positions Conrad so it's uh it
is intended to look practically at who's
succeeding but we're hoping to have a
conversation around
how this success may or may not apply to
your context and what it is that's
needed in a sense of organizational
capacity both in your I.T space and in
your training space and in your
investment in cloud-based services
to to test those hypotheses in this new
emergent uncertain world or all living
in at the moment so you do rely on on
real world business case studies and the
professors will be bringing to the table
or people who are you know getting their
hands dirty every day in this space this
course isn't about teaching R but
everyone I think who's a teaching in
this uh teaching and from the Wharton
School in this course is you know uses
are and a whole variety of different
data tools for extracting information
from unstructured data uh in their
regular research as I say R is the
preferred tool at Warden but there are
many many tools this isn't uh this the
issue isn't tools and the issue is in
data the issue is extracting
intelligence from data
um that also touched on it and brings us
to discussing why Wharton why
the Wharton School is
the best choice for
engaging in this investigation of AI
and yeah I can speak a little bit to
that from the point of view of uh of a
market positioning that the the our Dean
Erica James uh is uh interested in
putting in the marketplace so that
people who might have the luxury of
choosing between
an education at Wharton or Stanford or
Harvard or NCR or
ISB
Singapore management University all
these great schools around the world why
would you ever be interested in engaging
with the Wharton School or sending your
son and daughter or daughter to an MBA
program in a place like Wharton
and I think the answer to that or one of
the answers to that is the fact that
Wharton on a scale of being poetic to
being Quant oriented and I I use those
terms uh because of a kind of a famous
MBA blog that helps people pick MBA
schools to go to earlier in their career
that's called poets and quants
and on one end one could point to
Harvard as being the most poetic I think
of the classic big name Business Schools
in that their engagement with cases and
with senior leadership around the world
in intimate conversations around what
succeeded in their careers is
extraordinary and wonderful and a great
experience that's not this course that's
not what Wharton does what we do is
focus on metrics and data and financial
models and projections and the empirical
truth of what's going on so to give you
a flavor of that
when the Wharton School was founded in
1881 as the first business school
that was based around a college or
university in the world that was sort of
an invention in 1881 by Joseph Warden
and his work with some of the uh
economists and lawyers who were working
at the University of Pennsylvania at the
time to build out what was going to
become the curriculum under for
undergraduate business degrees and then
later for mbas in those days there was a
great deal of engineering happening
around
canals and waterways in the North
American continent which were critical
infrastructure for the growth of this
sort of Second Industrial Revolution
that was happening in North America at
the time and one of the major projects
of course was the effort to connect the
Pacific and Atlantic Oceans through the
Panama Canal well the government of uh
Teddy Roosevelt turned to Wharton
professors to help understand uh the
forecasts Financial modeling and P L
projections around this extraordinary
engineering feat called the Panama Canal
and he we turned on a term he turned to
Wharton School faculty for helping
inform those decisions around how
charges and tariffs were being developed
for shipping because we had studied a
similar activity in the North American
canals the Erie Canal systems that
connected the Northeast for example so
we've been involved with big data and
and deep into understanding forecasting
and predictive modeling since the 19th
century and then through the 20th
century
Wharton was the campus where the concept
of life insurance took shape the idea
that you could put a dollar value you on
a person's life and
develop Financial security systems for
for that the value of that life that you
could look at the entire functioning of
an economy as a series of sectors who
could be measured to develop uh outcome
metrics like gross national product all
that work was done at the Wharton School
the develop of marketing development of
marketing science largely accomplished
by the work of Paul Green some of the
work around conjun analysis done in the
1960s that moved marketing from being a
largely creative exercise again a poetic
exercise to a metrics driven approach to
understanding what works in in marketing
and what doesn't so it's been a long
history almost 150 years of being deeply
involved with the application of data
that is the reason why I can confidently
tell you that I think of all of the of
schools who put programs of study
together for you to look at
if what your
driving need is uh is associated with
the kinds of examples we've been trying
to describe the application of large
data sets uh
studied and analyzed using
state-of-the-art tools to inform real
world decisions that are being made on a
daily basis
then I think the Wharton School is as
well prepared as any partner you could
find to help you in that exploration but
I will say it's an exploration it's not
a matter of subtle science it's not like
we're teaching you calculus we're
exploring together as a community of
inquiry
a topic that is what we consider to be
both emergence unsettled science and
critically important
those are the topics that draw attention
from the the 250 members of the standing
faculty at the Wharton School from whom
we draw to present this class
great
that puts it in a
perfect context
um
the eligibility for this is is not based
on knowledge or experience or in
programming and Mathematics uh you don't
have to come in with that background
um but the ideal candidate for this
program is someone either at the c-suite
or the director level or senior level
managers Consultants that type of thing
so that
um people who are considering how
the application of AI will affect the
future course of their organization but
is that a fair summary
yes I would say so particularly those
who might be
high performing individuals in your
organization who have been tapped for
potential future leadership roles
oftentimes the enlarge organizations
c-suite Executives uh are their time is
in such demand that it might be
challenging for them to take on a
program of study like this so it might
be that the people who are close to the
c-suite or aspiring to see sweet roles
who would would find this course both
manageable as well as valuable and in
some organizations the responsibility
for looking at
Technologies and and
strategic future paths can be dispersed
down to an even lower level so
people have that level of responsibility
or are task with that are also great
candidates for that
um
we just talked about this
yeah I apologize for jumping the gun on
this one but yes if you if you want to
understand how you can make your
organization AI ready or you want to
understand
what specific proposals you might
start planning for introducing AI into
your business
um
and then the last category of managers
and leaders who want to build their own
capabilities so that they're prepared to
take on more responsibility in their
career
at higher levels in the organization so
all of the uh peoples at these levels
um
are ideal candidates for the program and
people who should really consider it I'm
going to ask this poll question
uh with regard to
[Music]
how much experience people have so that
they can get an assessment of where
people are in their careers of the folks
in the audience
and we'll just leave this open for about
20 seconds
and
close the pole in about five seconds
from now
get your answer in
here's the poll result
so about forty percent of the audience
are folks in the fresher category people
who are uh
new to the workforce
um on the other hand about a quarter of
the audience are people with more than
10 years of experience out in the
workforce and then
um
some folks of course in between
um
so there is a significant section of the
audience of people who are fairly
seasoned in their careers and then there
are a number of people who are
looking to move up
gain the tools and skills to advance in
their careers so what are your comments
on that
um
and I would say that for those who have
less than two years experience you may
want to take a deep look at what's
available on the market because it could
be that this is not targeted to help you
as as as as as well as other programs
might there's a program in data science
that Johns Hopkins I know does that I've
heard uh good things about particularly
for people who are kind of new to the
workforce that you may want to look at
and there are others too I know that
Stanford is increasing its portfolio in
the space aimed at engineering students
in particular so this is very much a
business course and so it's for people
who are
aspiring to
to understand new technologies in a way
that would accelerate their career
inside of business as a general manager
someone who ultimately is seeking out
Senior Management positioning so or it
could be Senior Management within a
technical organization if it's a larger
organization so just something to think
about that could be your you know uh
you're a fast starter and you want to uh
to uh learn what the language
that you need to use to talk to c-suite
Executives and use this as an
opportunity to engage that's that's an
opportunity but a good take a good look
at it if you're if you're in that a
category of less than two years yeah
there's also an interesting group of
people in the less than two years or two
to five years experience who are
entrepreneurs who have completed
academic training and are not actually
going to go out into the world and start
a new business and so there is kind of
um fast tracking into the level of the
senior manager your executive c-suite
executive and yeah
I've started several businesses myself
and I know that you you become a CEO
before you
you know before you're finished you know
uh programming your applications so um
yeah you have to kind of wear both hats
when you're you wear many many hats when
you're an entrepreneur so I can
understand their attraction to trying to
get ahead of this technology
particularly things you can invest in
that's shown a good reasonable track
record these can be expensive projects
AI projects very often undertaken
successfully by just very large
organizations but there are some
applications that are emerging that are
available for uh for purchase through
the cloud that we'll show you some
examples of as well yeah and so as John
mentioned this is a business course we
have simply learned offers so they're
technical courses
for people who are interested in gaining
the tools and experience to
actually build and develop
AI uh pools but this program is
different from that and It prepares you
in a different way
so going through the uh
curriculum here uh don you might want to
just tell how The Experience plays out
for people who are going to take on a
three-month program with you
sure so we started that bottom
foundations level where we try to cover
uh quickly some of the basics of the
technology platforms that Ai and machine
learning are built on by the way none of
this is very watered down and it's not
watered down at all this is directly
from the courses that are taught to our
doctoral students and MBA students on
these same Topics by the same faculty we
then bring in people from the customer
analytics initiative to talk about the
uh how AI applications in the marketing
world are working we then in the third
module will look again at the finance
domain talking with a research scientist
from our finance department
we then move on to the trickiest of the
group which is HR management we'll be
bringing in Matthew Bidwell from our
people analytics initiative and then
we'll look more broadly at the whole set
of issues associated with governance and
the nature of the impact of AI uh on the
general economics of our organizations
and industries and that's very much
fluid uh as some people have said in the
Q a section uh AI is increasingly
automating a variety of white-collar
jobs that we were thought were would
never be touched by forces of Automation
in the past but they are now
they're also are generating
opportunities for new kinds of White
Collar jobs particularly for those
people who can play that translator role
who can understand how to how to Marshal
the forces of technology to drive a
theory of the firm
and
here's just a smattering of the
technology or the not the technology I'm
sorry The Faculty the program faculty
from
uh Wharton who participate in this
program
these are your colleagues Tom yes yeah I
know them all the uh so you'll see here
a representation from multiple academic
departments at the Wharton School
including legal studies and business
ethics Kevin werbach was in the Obama
Administration guiding uh some of the
regulatory initiatives around the space
Sunny Tom Bay is a brilliant uh new uh
faculty member associate professor of
operations who is deeply involved in
running our AI for business Research
Center
Etc I won't go through them all but
they're all very well respected
professors all tenured their job is to
be on top of the best research in this
space that's okay we're sort of running
out of time here so I should all right
all right and uh
so just one quick poll based on what
you've heard so far are you interested
in enrolling in this partner
straightforward question yeah sometimes
the easiest way to get an answer a
question is just ask it simply
uh while we're doing the summit has a
question popped up saying is this a
simply learned course or question Warren
the course is from Wharton so Wharton is
a you know a East Coast U.S in an Ivy
League school with a beautiful campus
and we're in no position to deliver a
course globally I would argue that there
isn't a single Ivy League school or ivy
league plus school that's in a position
to deliver 24 7 365 in multiple
languages we all need Partners to do
that simply learn as our partner for
this course thank you yeah uh and just
to make that
we are simply learning offers some
courses on our own which are
technological
digital skills oriented
aligned to Industry requirements those
are
um
skills training for people who are
interested in upskilling and reskilling
in particular areas but we partner with
universities to help them deliver a
different
category of knowledge and this is a
particularly good example of that where
beer acting as the delivery partner to
provide a platform
for content and
knowledge that's being transmitted by
Wharton
the poll result shows that about three
quarters of our audience is interested
in applying so let me
briefly
talk about the enrollment steps it's a
three-step process you email us at ask
us at simplywing.net as we're the
administrator
help Wharton with this
review your prerequisites again the
prerequisites are pretty straightforward
and then on approval we send you an
admission offer the next cohort for this
program starts on December 22nd
um you have two pricings one is for U.S
students which is 35 30 35 3 000 US
dollars
um that's pretty much the uh pricing
worldwide except in India of course
where it's denominated in
rupee one lock 35
000. and that can be financed out over
time it
no cost interest or no interest
financing
um we also remind people to ask their
employers about tuition reimbursement
for Executive Education since that's
often
benefit that your employer will offer
you but again that's completely up to
the employer not not uh Warden or simply
learned but again to reach out
email her to ask us at simplylearn.net
I will put that email address into the
chat box here
and
that way it'll be at your fingertips
and there we go
and
quick additional question if you're
interested recorders of you have said
that
um
now that you've seen the pricing how
soon do you plan to enroll want to do
that in the
um
December cohort are you looking at
something further out
that's what this go for it but
15 20 seconds here
all right
okay
so uh
a number of you are interested in doing
this quickly
um in the December cohort maybe the one
after and uh some more of you are
interested in looking at within six
months out
um and for those of you who are looking
further out we do encourage you to email
us so that you can stay in touch and
keep track of developments in the
program but we understand that
I mean
in terms of your personal experience and
uh personal career plans
um is a choice that you need to make so
I'm Stuart I may have lost you
we are approaching the bottom of the
hour so I want to thank everybody for
your participation today and for your
many questions I realized we didn't get
to a lot of the questions in the Q a
panel so uh you can reach out to the ask
us email address that Stuart shared to
try to get your answers uh uh about this
program for those of you who are not
thinking about taking it uh or getting
involved with programs to study around
this sometime in the future you may want
to keep
your eye on the Wharton Research Center
websites so if you go to
www.warton.upen.edu and click on
Research you'll see various white papers
and
descriptions of activities that the
research faculty I mentioned post as a
regular basis
so and uh with that I'm going to bid you
a good day and hope that you stay safe
and well and that are you are successful
in all your efforts to advance your
professional career
yeah here are you uh hearing me now John
I am now yes we lost you for a while
yeah same thing that happened to you
earlier happened to me just now so yeah
again I apologize to our uh audience and
we'll finish out the
presentation first off do we have
questions and answers
that we want to take what what have you
seen in the Q a box that the
um let's see
I think I we answered several of them uh
someone asked questions is it is this a
free program do I have to pay for it I
think you've got the answer that this
you know there are ways to study this
material for free you have to have you
have to be disciplined and you have to
look a little harder so you won't have
the help that simply everyone could
provide you in exploring it but as I say
if you go to the Wharton website and
look at look at some of those research
centers there's some free white papers
you can get
um
here's a question
um from Sandra which
applies to what Conrad is saying earlier
he asks how can AI be used in marketing
and that relates to the example Conrad
gave of when an organization is just
trying to take in information from
receipts and then use that for a bonus
program
how would you use that so can you
comment on that because I do have a
comment if
so
um
one of the areas where uh marketing
faculty and researchers are trying to
understand how to extract data is in the
constantly evolving set of constraints
around
e-commerce and digital marketing so both
IOS and Android are increasingly moving
away from the use of cookies on sites
and as a result of
European security measures are there
other kind of constraints around
collecting profile data on individuals
all of that's constantly sending
marketers to new sources of data for
extracting the kinds of information that
describe that drives decisions around
things like product characteristics and
product roadmaps and pricing and
Etc et cetera all the elements
associated with the offering a product
on the market so AI is very very
important in the field of
okay
and I'm hoping that Don hasn't just
lost his connection but
um yep uh I will offer uh Insight on to
here he is the application of um
marketing
AI
in the particular example that Conrad
used which is
bonus programs when you're looking at
bonus programs for uh points
accumulation programs for retail
one of the things that AI helps with is
understanding the purchase patterns
and it feeds back into
what offers you're going to be
recommended
um so for example
CVS which is a
large farm Pharmacy chain in the United
States
has a well-established program and they
uh
print out very famously the the very
long receipt which shows all the
different offers that you that's driven
and by AI you know that if you purchased
a certain set of things in the past and
you're purchasing a certain set of
things today the AI engine can
make recommendations on the Fly and
adjust the offers that it gives you in
terms of discounts
based on
its analysis of your propensity to buy
so it can give you a bigger offer if it
feels that that would induce you to make
a purchase and give you a smaller offer
if it knows that you're likely to make
the purchase anyway and just need a
small incentive so those are examples of
how this would work
um
because John has lost his connection I
am just going to go ahead go to the end
of this uh process and I apologize but
we will be sharing a recording of this
session
and
here is
our last question for you
for people who are interested in
enrolling are you interested in getting
assistance from us
ask this last poll question really quick
all right I'm still showing that one
basically yes no question very quickly
all right
and we'll close the poll in about five
seconds here
all right
so for those of you who are looking to
get assistance in enrolling please do
contact us at ask us simplylearn.net of
course that QR code will take you to the
program page
on our website which will tell you more
about the program allow you to download
the syllabus
and contact our learning Consultants
again with that I'm going to
conclude the webinar today I want to
thank everyone for being here
I would like to thank Don
for being generous with his time and
um
knowledge today
and we hope that we can welcome you into
the Wharton online learning community so
looking forward to hearing from you and
thanks again for being here today